petit
bricool bonjour et bienvenue dans
l'émission Les petits bricoleurs je vous
propose aujourd'hui de réaliser un bijou
de sac pour la fête des
mamans pour cela nous avons besoin d'un
mousqueton ou d'un anneau
quelques
rubans un
bouton du fil et une aiguille et
quelques décorations comme des
perles des
Pierr des petites
fleurs des petits
cœurs alors donc nous allons faire le
montage donc on va va prendre toutes les
rubans de différentes grandeurs de
différentes
grandeurs donc on va les mettre
ensemble on prend son mousqueton donc on
fait passer tous les
rubans à
l'intérieur bon après si c'est trop
grand pourra couper les
ruban
voilà maintenant on va coudre le bouton
là mais si vous n'avez pas de bouton par
exemple vous pouvez faire aussi un nœud
ça j'aêne pas vous pouvez faire aussi un
nœud donc là on va mettre le bouton
alors je vais prendre mon
aiguille que j'ai déjà enfilé
auparavant
et on cous son
bouton on repasse une troisième fois et
on fait un petit mœud
derrière voilà donc ça va vous donner
ça et ensuite il suffit de rajouter les
petites
décorations alors donc on va mettre la
petite
perle
on va faire un N pas que la p
tombe on peut aussi rajouter notre
petite
perle ce que ça donne en enfant la
perle on peut la laisser là comme
ça on fait toujours un
nœud ça la per ne tomourbe
pas
donc on va coller quelques pierres alors
je de colle
là et on va coller sur le blanc par
exemple
voilà voilà on a mis quelques pierres un
petit cœur vous pouvez même rajouter une
petite fleur et vous pouvez écrire aussi
bonne fête maman maman je t'aime le
prénom de la maman comme vous
voulez on va rajouter par exemple la
petite fleur
là voilà ce que ça
donne je vais raccourcir un petit peu
là alors non racossir moi je coupe en B
là
voilà après si vous voulez rajouter
d'autres décorations vous pouvez
rajouter ou sinon vous pouvez laisser
comme
ça le bijou de sac étant terminé
j'espère que ça vous a plu
il me reste qu'à souhaiter à toutes les
mamans une bonne fête et à la prochaine
émission au
revoir petit
bricoleur